[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2019 ball chess
classic my name is Caleb Denby and I'm
joined for the last time today by
grandmaster Patrick wolf all right it's
a pleasure to have you here again
there's a lot going on today there's
yeah we had some surprise shake ups
after our show ended yesterday we
expected the Seif Dhirubhai Lee to at
least draw his game to maintain his lead
in the a group but actually he ended up
losing that position and now we have an
astounding situation in Group A and so
why don't we actually take a look at
that situation with the Group A
standings and there we see so with vez
efz round four loss we actually have
four players tied for the lead in Group
A with four more chasing just a half
point behind clearly in this tournament
is anybody's anybody's chance daro also
lost his game yesterday with var and Ray
both winning to move into this
leadership position definitely crazy
crazy tournament standing here with
eight out of ten players really on on
the button for winning this tournament
and why don't we actually take a look at
Group B standings as well Jackson buyuk
only managed a draw yesterday in a very
interesting an interesting game against
manuel Petrosyan I believe and Yassir
Quesada Perez actually managed to win
once again bringing him to three and a
half out of four so now jack has been
caught and it'll be interesting to see
what he does today to try and take this
clear first position back or maybe yes
sir we'll be the one to to jump into
first place
and why don't we head on over and see
the tournament format for this event
it's a pretty interesting one it's quite
similar to the World Cup actually there
are two ten players round robins which
isn't similar to the World Cup but the
time control is exactly the same it's
90 minutes for the first 40 moves with
30 minutes added on for the remainder of
the game
after move 40 and there is a 30-second
increment starting from move one there's
also a draw rule in effects where the
players are not allowed to offer a draw
to each other until black has made his
thirtieth move as always thank you guys
for joining us here on YouTube
just search st. Louis chess club on
YouTube fall chess classic and you'll
find us here we're keeping an eye on the
chat if you guys have any questions for
us question for questions for the
players once we get them in for an
interview we'd love to hear them we'd
love to respond to you guys you can also
get involved on Twitter using the
hashtag fall chess classic and if you
want to see the games for yourself
follow along look at any game you want
you can do so from u.s. chess champs
calm well with that in minds what do you
think about the games today Patrick
what's going on well there's some recent
games and one actually that's over
already that we should take a look at
because that was pretty exciting yeah
but there's there's one game I'd love to
jump into right away in the B group
actually yet so why don't we take a look
at the B group pairings and see where we
stand there so Victor mihailovski is
paired against Aman Hamilton around man
Cobian has drawn his game already
against men well petrosyan yes sir
Quezada Perez is paired against San Beda
Craig Orion Dennis Gaede Rick is paired
against Alexander fear and then this key
matchup of the day I think is the one
you want to take a look at Jack
shouldn't bully AK who is leading the B
group with yes sir Quesada Perez is
paired against Steven Zurich and the
game is in a very critical position
right now yes so without further ado
let's take a look at what's going on
yeah let's jump into the analysis of
this so if you if you take a minute to
absorb the board you can see already
it's a little bit of a crazy game both
things look exposed but actually blacks
King is paradoxically much more exposed
than whites black is almost but not
quite at this point on the verge of
being checkmated but he's got everything
sort of controlled and of course right
here we have the Bishop attacking the
Queen here and so the question is where
should black move the Queen that's a
trick question because the answer is he
shouldn't he actually should play this
pretty incredible move
look here to d3 Wow
yeah I'm gonna explain why in a moment
first let's take a look at why should
block not move the Queen let's suppose
for example black moves the Queen to f4
very natural very natural move right but
in this case white actually wins
immediately by playing Queen takes
Knight pawn takes rook g7 King eh-eh and
now just work g4 and you snag the Queen
yeah King is very much stuck on this
h-file
so okay maybe black should move the
Queen somewhere else so what if black
moves the Queen is let's say Queen c2
maybe Queen c2 also a natural looking
move I'm just trying to hide from that
rook yeah exactly
but it turns out actually that after
white plays this move rook g5 the threat
of just breaking through here on h5 just
is overwhelming and there there's
basically nothing that black can do
about it even sort of like try to
wriggle around a bit but in roof t1
check y can simply take and play she
should eat one yes correct
of course it'd be a mistake to play king
G - yes because then that would well I
guess it's no it ya think GT would be
fine as well well there's team cheated
on the night well just very quickly to
show here takes takes you don't play
King G - not because of night at 4 cuz
that night spin but because if Queen
takes pawn defending the knight as well
but you just play Bishop e1 and it's
basically over rook takes Knight is
gonna be lights out so the correct move
it turns out in this position is for
block to play this pretty extraordinary
looking move and we have to wonder
whether Stephen xeric is going to find
this moon it's a very difficult move to
have to play very difficult moves now I
still don't fully see the idea if white
simply captures the rook well how do you
capture the work with the pawn so if you
capture with the pawn now you get to
capture this bishop okay and now
actually it's it's a very unclear
position in fact because black has some
compensation for the exchange and now
without that Bishop the attacks kind of
slowed down to a crawl there really
isn't any any way to break
through here right it seems like that
the epon was pretty critical for
defending the white king as well yeah
that it's on d3
there are a bit more problems so in fact
the better move is to play Queen takes
d3 out of course and now
pawn takes Bishop takes pawn takes
knight and pawn takes pawn and okay
White has an extra exchange it's better
position for white but it's not over yet
it's better position for white to be
sure but we have to we have to wonder
whether in fact he's gonna find the one
move to keep the game going
or instead whether it's gonna be lights
out very soon so be interesting to see
what happens if I was calculating earth
d3 from afar that final position looks
very very scary to me I would think like
rook g5 for white there might might
almost win the game just my king is
stuck on the h-file still and and with
the two rooks I don't know if that's the
best that I can do I think black isn't
some serious trouble so I'm sorry Queen
takes d3 instead yeah no it's not clear
because if white plays rook g5 then
Queen takes d3 check well excuse me
Queen takes rook obviously so Queen
takes d3 rather than pawn takes d3 I
think sorry what we're looking at Queen
takes D 3 instead of pawn takes D 3
right yeah so I didn't understand what
you were what you were sister yeah just
the line that we went down here so yeah
he takes Bishop takes pawn takes f5 yeah
oh so you're playing so upon taking -
King - yeah and then I was looking at
rookie for g5 here yeah yeah no it's
it's a for sure it's a better position
for white well I was just thinking like
King G - Rick h1 I can declare checkmate
almost well I mean we can well I mean we
can keep going down this rabbit hole if
you'd like I mean I'd like you to trust
me for now that it's a better position
for white without question but it's not
over yet okay
whereas if he doesn't find rook d3 it's
over so it'll be interesting to see what
happens by the way a side note here is
that the this position this game is
pretty crazy I'm backing up a bit and in
fact here in this position and you may
you may be asking how do we
to this position well it's it was a
crazy game but I'm white actually did
not find the right move here queen h3
which he played is a good move but it
turns out in fact that there was even a
stronger move simply by taking on g7
right away so a lot of fireworks we've
gotten to this position here and now
black has to try to find the one move to
hang on for a bit longer or see whether
the game's gonna be over very quickly
yeah rook d3 is there any way that that
white can go wrong well that's gonna
take the rook but a very interesting
position alright so how much time does
Stephen have it looks like he still has
quite a bit of time to try to figure
this one out so I'm sure he'll be in the
think tank for a long time here yeah
what working on this very complicated
position yeah yeah it was very
interesting to see that King Ani one
with three pawns in front of it like
yeah another game that might be worth
taking a look at is actually one that's
over but it was quite an exciting game
where Jordan just ripped through his
opponent yeah absolutely
so um we can see the final position here
if we sort of count the pieces you'll
see that White has two extra bishops so
obviously black was right to resign but
maybe we could take a quick quick look
yeah there's a very very fun tactic yeah
you would manage manage to play in this
game yep so let's let's just click
through this game quickly you'll see
it's an Alec eins defense white gets a
pleasant position nothing terribly
exciting but just sort of space
advantage and a little bit little bit
nicer game for white a little bit freer
game game develops pretty naturally for
a while nothing much happening here and
then in a move or two we're going to see
this move by block so back here I'd say
this is a very normal looking position a
little better for white I'd certainly
rather have white and block but playable
for both sides absolutely but here black
played this tactic or this move a base
on tactic that I
was just a mistake so white took on age
six and black took on age three hmm so
the idea being that pawn takes Bishop
actually turns out to be very bad
because Queen takes pawn and now you
can't play Bishop takes Bishop because
you just go Queen g4 check fall by
Knight f4 yeah pretty interesting
sacrificed by black yeah so you can see
this this obviously would be pretty bad
and the night singing checkmate is
threatened it's tough to save everything
for life so going back to Bishop takes
h3 but white simply played 95 and once
uh once you take a look at this position
with the exchange of the pair of H bonds
it turns out that white is the one
that's benefited enormously from this
because with the extra space blacks King
is much more exposed as much more easy
to take care of advantage of the blacks
more exposed King game White's King
especially with this dark squared Bishop
getting traded yep so we'll see black
did in fact take the knight white took
back black brought the Bishop back
already the computer is literally giving
white the advantage of four pawns I mean
it's that bad of a position we'll play a
few more moves through the game and then
here perhaps not quite not quite yet
we're coming up to just excited I'm so
excited so white pushes the night away
placed upon the sea floor black moves
the knight to b4 it turns out actually
the strongest move here is probably just
to move this rook to h4 right away
this actually probably wins immediately
instead white plays rook e3 also an
extremely good move bringing in the last
piece yeah well not the last piece but
more pieces and I'm and really this
position is is basically lost for black
but black in in trying to find some
defense plate is Knight to g7 which
allowed white immediately to take the
bishop on f5 that's justice very nice
tactic you're talking about so now if
black takes the Queen it's simply over
after rook g3 check you move the King
either h7 or H a rook age four and
basically it's gonna be checkmate very
soon then very
SiC checkmate with the t-rex so instead
after after Queen takes f5 black had
nothing better than like Queen takes and
after Queen takes Knight takes rook
takes well this is the final position
White's up to bishops of black design
right well that was actually an
interesting game in the a group so why
don't we take a look at the rest of the
pairings in the a group and then a quick
look at our key matchup at eventually in
the a group Ilyas Mirren is paired
against vara Cobian who is leading the
tournament with +1 along with three
other players received herb Olli another
one of those players tied for first
place is up against Alex epitaphs and
now your Donora staff tur defeating
alexander bortnik also moves to +1 so
like I said it's anybody's game in the a
group here daro spirits is paired
against frontal Cumaean and then our key
matchup of the day is between two
players that are at +1
Alexander Linderman and Ray Robson they
took kind of different paths to get here
alex has been playing very solid chests
he's had an advantage and almost all of
his games I think but was only able to
convert in one of those positions I mean
while ray has had a bit of an
up-and-down tournament he had a very
quick draw in round 1 actually lost in
round 2 but he came back strong with two
wins in the previous two rounds and what
kind of position do these two players
have right now well as you pointed out
Letterman's been playing very solidly
and we have a very solid looking
position on the board so I would say you
know Garry Kasparov used to talk about a
symbolic advantage so the idea of a
symbolic advantage is it looks like it's
better but really when you look at it it
isn't anything right and I would say
that's what this position is so
certainly white does have the better
pawn structure because black does have
this isolated pawn on d5 and white has
very good control of the blockading d4
square
you know blocks in no position to push
the pawn right now so yes you know
nominally white has an advantage the
black has perfectly active pieces and
there's only one weakness the only this
d5 pawn I would say really is no
advantage whatsoever and the computer
agrees and not only does the computer
think this
as equal the computer is actually
completely agnostic as to whether black
should push the pawn to g5 or instead
push the pawn to h5 and when you see
these positions we're now sort of
bouncing around maybe things like blacks
should move its King to h7 I don't
really understand what the idea of that
move would be but but the basic idea is
that black can kind of pass and yet and
and it's still equal it's another one of
those situations where something that
strikes me is Lina White's King there's
always going to be pressure down this C
file and you can kind of imagine maybe
some major pieces get traded off along
that file because if white were to
abandon it then there's always threats
of Brooks coming in to c2 and there's no
more C 3 X or C 3 square leaders those
weak pawns on B 3 and into e3 yeah so
tough for white to really don't do much
without you know risking something in
return
ya know I think that's how I mean of
course the game is going on it you know
could change we'll see what happens but
I would place a reasonably high
probability of a draw in this position
although you know plenty pieces still on
the board and Ray does only have about
thirteen and a half minutes at this
point for the next ten move so and where
Alexander has almost half an hour so
yeah we'll have to see what happens
right well I guess we can go to
whichever game you want now if I had the
choice I think var a Kobe ins position
is looking quite interesting it seems
like Elias Mirren is actually running
into some some difficulties this
tournament if anybody I think has been
the target in a group so far I think
it's actually been him despite you know
obviously he's he's like chess legend
he's challenged some of the best players
in the world and don't done quite well
but in this tournament things not quite
going according to plan
yeah I think offered the choice between
white or black I would take black in
this position the computer agrees thinks
black has a reasonable advantage half a
pawn or so the computer is completely
agnostic at this point as to where the
whites should move the rook here to e1
or instead whether Y should move the
knight to c1 presumably with the idea of
bouncing quick
to d3 but I mean if it were my choice
certainly I'd be more inclined to look
at this move Knight c1 just because I
sort of understand what the ideas yeah
but black has more space black has
active pieces obviously this long
diagonal here
although the nagging pressure definitely
some nagging pressure now of course the
the Queen and Bishop are sort of not
quite lined up the way you'd want them
to take advantage now and and right now
white can defend by pushing the group to
f2 and control this critical square
g-tube if only Queens can jump over
pieces yeah well different so so
certainly White's okay here obviously
this will take a few moves but as black
my problem piece I assume to have to my
bishop on b6 it's serving a purpose its
defending my pawn but especially my
knight on e7 is not really pulling its
way sure so I'd love to play Knight to
c8 bring it in to d6 and then all of a
sudden I'm looking at very nice squares
look up efore square yep and so totally
agree with that and in fact in all lines
this is the computers next couple of
moves for block literally just to
reposition the knife from a seven to see
a to d6 which not only activates the
knight but also uncovers the rook along
this file so I completely agree with you
okay
it's a easier position for block to play
yes slight edge but very natural moves
to follow you know maybe white has some
natural moves as well of course he can
improve his knight in much the same
manner but I think with easy moves to
follow it's going to end up being
difficult for white in this game yeah I
would agree this is an interesting
situation where okay so he has played
the night to c1 which as we were saying
to it seemed like the most logical move
and we'll have to see at this moment the
computer is actually agnostic between
moving the knight to see a or moving the
Bishop to e4 also a perfectly reasonable
centralizing move I think probably the
more human move is to move the Knight to
c8 just because it's very easy move to
play and it keeps a lot of options open
right we'll have to see what happens
Bishop before might be anticipating the
white knight landing on e5 or something
and just removing that bishop from any
any situation where it could be capped
oh sure well I think it just sort of
centralized system yeah the control and
just sort of increases blacks general
control over the board but I think what
we have here is definitely a position
that's more favorable for a Cobian Ilias
under pressure here and you know he's
it's going to be interesting to see
whether he's able to find a defensive
plan or if he's just gonna have to keep
holding against difficult pressure
before we jump off this game I was
actually a question from the YouTube
chat it seems as though var took over 20
minutes for his move Knight g5 early on
in the opening okay now do you have any
thoughts on why that might be I'm
actually not familiar with the position
where you played no g5 yes well let's
let's bounce very quickly to that so
sorry if I'm going very a little bit
quickly this is a Tarrasch French and
you know white played Knight gf3 and
then C takes e4 Knight takes e4 Knight
c6 and eventually white traded the
knight on c6 so that I would get any
position perhaps they meant to say Nate
g6 I probably 96 yeah so I can't say why
he took so long to decide on this move
it's a perfectly reasonable move
obviously making way for the bishop to
develop but but ya know I mean I'm not
familiar with the latest theory in this
position but just from my basic
knowledge of having played these setups
with white before I would say frankly it
really isn't much of anything for white
yeah and I don't like actually it's
pretty easy play to explain why it may
be black took so long there's always
this moment out of the opening for me at
least where it's like okay you know I
know now the character of the position I
know what kind of line my opponent has
chosen and you just you take a minute to
you know reefa milliards yourself with
the ideas take a look at what white's
plans are and then decide on the best
the best course of action there's always
this moment where you kind of settle
down get into the real pace of the game
stop playing just your theory and
immediately yeah and probably that's
that one that's what was going on here
so since we're in this we'll just sort
of very quickly a cycle through the
moves to get to where we are right now
in the game white played Bishop III in
this position to develop and allow
himself block this block this bishops
diagonal
and so both sides castled
black plate c5 taking space in the
center white plate c4 which stops the
black pawn from advancing but at the
same time allows black this protected
past pawn here on d4 f5 very very
logical move taking more space
stopping white from ever pushing the F
pawn himself and after I mean we could
basically almost see the shape of the
position on the board from this and so
as you obviously you can tell at some
point white exchange pawns on f5 ie
right now and then just some piece
exchanges and and rima new verrines and
here we are
alright very interesting position well
I'll let you decide now what looks
interesting to you let's see well I've
been so wrapped up in these last couple
games they've been a lot to talk about
today no I I do want to mention actually
Stevens Erick has decided on his moves
and it looks as though he has decided on
rook to d3
yeah let's back there so we rack we
actually now have a position very
similar to the one we were considering
just a few a few minutes ago so we'll go
back to the critical moment here we go
yeah so they they followed that exact
computer line action yeah
so black gum puts the rook on d3 what it
takes between Queen's come off pawn
takes Knight rook g5 97 tactics pawn is
an interesting decision here white could
have decided instead to move the bishop
to c3 which the computer recommends and
also looks very logical to me and ran
and seems like but at any rate he
decided instead just to take the pawn
and this allows black to move the knight
around so on the one hand White's
captured this pawn before blocks able to
take the check but on the other hand
White's a little bit slower to bring the
bishop around Stephens chosen this setup
to solve this problem yeah yeah and that
was my question earlier is it seems as
though the black King is going to be
weak but with the second night on e6 it
really controls a lot of the important
squares so you know it's interesting the
computer so let's let's sort of give the
computer a few seconds to sort
come up to speed and decide what it what
it thinks but basically white is better
to be sure but this is by no means an
over and done Geng the best move
according to the computer and certainly
a move that makes a lot of sense to me
to me is to play Knight h5 and now the
point is you know if you move you're up
to h3 actually it's not that scary
because you can defend this night you
come white can't bring the King up
either to e2 or g2 because in either
case this night would come here and
forth the king and the rook and so you
you kind of see both the strength and
the weakness of the bishop here the
bishop is is very nice on c3 controlling
all of these dark squares but black has
simply put all of his pieces on the
light squares to try to defend his King
yes and and also there's nothing that
this Bishop is coordinating with right
now right it would like to coordinate
with the rook but the rook can't come to
this g3 square because the knight here
obviously controls it and white can't
bring the King up to either one of these
squares as we talked about a moment
before so this rook here on H on a1 is a
little bit out of the game
meanwhile the black rook pretty active
so it seems like white has made it has
left himself with actually a difficult
technical task whereas earlier on in the
game perhaps he was just winning yeah
and and in fact
Knight age 5 has been played now the
computer thinks and I certainly agree
that rather than moving the rotation yes
moving the e3 is a better move like
there's no point to work age because
King g6 defends everything so might as
well put the work in a more active
Square well while this game is still
going on someone in the YouTube chat is
interested in the Alexander at the table
game which Sun is something that
interests me as well yes like Massif
Dhirubhai Lee things are starting to go
quite wrong for him he was off to an
early lead in the tournament but with
that loss yesterday and now looking like
a very very tough position today things
are turning around yeah no this has he
he's really completely lost
control of what had been a perfectly
fine position so how did we get here
first of all yeah let's let's go let's
cycle through the game quickly so we can
see so very funny okay now we six yeah
so a little bit of a latency issue with
the computer so I'm gonna cycle through
as quickly as it will allow me so you
know white white has I mean this this
efj I've moved by the way is an
interesting choice what's your opinion
of openings like one be six how should
white try to play in order to take
advantage of it do you just play natural
moves solid Center develop your pieces
or do you go I think there's nothing
wrong with white setup here I'm a little
less sure about developing the bishop
out to g5 as soon as he did but my main
question is like you seen this move if I
it happen quite early so in my opinion
white has gone for something where he's
trying to immediately punish black he's
saying you can't play this slowly with
b6 I'm gonna open it up right away
whereas I feel like in other situations
another player might just you know
castle is king bring the rooks to the
center play it a bit more slowly and I
was wondering what your opinion of of
that was I think it really depends on
your style yeah I mean it depends on
your style and it depends on how well
prepared you are I would tend not to
initiate fireworks so quickly unless I
had a lot of confidence right that it
was the right thing to do if I'd
prepared it ahead of time but at any
rate it you know it's not that it didn't
work out it just didn't really get much
for white I mean we can we can see is
this as we sort of cycle through these
moves this looks a little bit like a
pure defense for block where he's
managed to free himself pretty well
actually
and as we just keep sort of cycling
through the early opening moves we could
see that you know yeah already special
already this pawn on e5 is well it's I
don't think the pawn on e5 is a weakness
I think it's perfectly well defended
okay I just think that there's really
nothing special here for white I'd like
blocks developed all of his pieces it's
not so much a weakness but my point was
gonna be it's kind of stunting white
zone bishop on g3 yeah my daddy v square
might be better used for an
Bishop rather than this pawn so in this
in this position here black made a very
interesting choice to take the pawn on a
for very dynamic choice very imbalancing
things but even though it's very dynamic
choice in terms of sort of stylistically
what it does in terms of the actual
evaluation of the position it doesn't
really change that much basically still
an equal position but what happened but
you know it is very imbalancing again
stylistically because you do have this
bishop that one day could become very
powerful if white doesn't sort of
maintain control that's basically what
happens so white has this extra pawn but
on the other hand black has the two
bishops it's very powerful LightSquared
bishop probably a fairly dynamically
equal position and as we just sort of
keep going here what we'll see is black
managed to keep improving his position
reasonably well and white made a bit of
a bit of an error by putting this knight
on d4 yeah
leaving all of his pieces hanging
somehow but well the problem is after
this pawn to g4 so we've now caught up
to where we are in the game right if
I'll just briefly show the people
watching whitey played this night on b3
to d4 oops sorry about that I've got
this it's updating automatically so I'm
gonna click back apologize after Knight
bTW for Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen black push the pawn to g4 and now
the problem is this Knight really
doesn't have a good place to go because
if you if you try to move this knight
black is gonna take the knight on d4 and
you have this pin here against the rook
on against opponent see if he gets that
work on c1 I'm not really sure what
White was thinking here yet but nine to
five black can simply capture this
knight on f3 yes so that's exactly right
pawn takes Knight I thought I understood
tack yes no pawn takes Knight is
actually going to win material and
frankly looks to me like it's gonna win
the game pretty quickly so of course
well they sure what what Alexander was
thinking but looks like he just
blundered there yeah maybe we should
show the line of course there is this
knight take c7 move to worry about but
at the end of the day the rook on e2 is
also
right and that's the main problem that's
correct so this is exactly right yes why
can't a con c8 but block can take on e2
and after Knight takes rook pawn takes
rook a quick count shows that block does
have an extra piece and oh by the way
also this pawn on e2 is a monster the
big by the way yeah so not looking good
all right so that's huge news for the a
group just after our show yesterday I
expected you know Dhirubhai Lee to draw
his game maintain the clear first
position and then go into today feeling
good but maybe that loss has has shaken
him a little bit yeah this is not the
the chest that we've seen from him in
the first half or the first couple
rounds of this tournament yeah so we'll
see that in fact what did move the rook
to e3 was a sensible move but white is
at this point just a piece down so I
think we have to expect it blocks gonna
win should be very good okay so so let's
see I think we have covered the most
exciting game right but we should cover
a few of the other games too just so
people can see what's happening maybe
finish round out the a group oh yeah I
think the only game that we haven't
talked about in the a group is this game
between Dara's fruits and rotten
illumine yeah just actually ended in a
draw yeah so like it's not much
happening there yeah but we we can
briefly show I think what happened in
the opening if people interested in
seeing it was a scotch opening and again
apologize for the latency here but this
is a well known variation of the of the
scotch this move h4 is sort of a modern
treatment of it used to be played for
right away but at any rate what happened
is after this f6 move pawn takes Knight
takes the Queen's came off fairly soon
it took I took another few moves but the
Queen's did come off and with the rooks
having come off as well you can see that
there really wasn't a whole lot to play
for it was still some imbalance in the
position but nobody did anything wrong
right and just just not really any
advantage fry this
and so the fact that it petered out to a
draw not too surprising we'll just sort
of click through so people can see the
the final moves here but it just ended
up being a repetition we see the
repetition there and it's all calm so
yeah interesting stuff for the a group
now that's bouncing down into the B
group yeah
let's cover maybe the slightly more
interesting game which that is the game
that has not been agreed drawn and that
is yes Cassata yeah of course that
Yassir Quesada Perez is one of the
leaders in the B group coming into today
yeah he is competing with Jackson buyuk
who like we said has a tough technical
chat a technical task against even
Zurich to try to make a full point so
what has yesterday in his quest to score
the win here well I mean just just
taking in the position before we go over
any variations a couple fact a couple
things are sort of impressed themselves
one is White's pieces White's rooks in
particular certainly look much more
active than blacks works so rooks like
opened files White's rooks
have this open file here and of course
the rook has this open file here so
White's two rooks are sort of operating
on open channels there's also this
square here and this pawn here which of
course is well defended now but still is
a target on the other hand blacks works
are sort of sitting on there just sort
of blocked up obviously this work on g7
not doing anything right now but more to
the point this efile this F file they're
both sort of hitting on granite here and
yes you could try to push this pawn on
d5 to try to loosen things up a little
bit
seems like that's a bike's main source
of counter play here but that but that
would leave the c5 pawn more exposed so
right so from a pieces perspective
White's works more out of more active
than blacks whites not a knight on e4
very well placed now it is true that
black has the two bishops and in the
long run the to bishops could very
easily prove to be an important factor
right now not doing so much right so I
would say that white is
slightly to be preferred here however
there really isn't it's not very clear
what white is going to do so if you if
you're looking for weaknesses we did
talk about that pawn on b7 yes but it is
well defended by the bishop there is
this pawn on d6 yes but it is very well
defended by the other bishop
I think a draw probably the most likely
outcome here but we'll have to see yeah
I would prefer white for the moment yeah
but totally agree with you give it a
couple moves black might play something
like rook c7 and then Bishop d7 if you
give him the chance yep and once this
bishop moves from c8 to c6 blacks pieces
make a much less bad impression that's
true although even with the bishop on c6
it's still not clear exactly how you're
gonna activate that much at some point
block is gonna have to try the put I
mean that you're right the plan is at
some point to push the pawn to d5 when
this pawn on c5 is not a liability but
but can be used more dynamically right I
think if white is alert that probably
should not be allowed I think white is
probably four choice here but very
unclear whether either side can make any
progress fair enough
so that's how the two leaders in the a
group or the B group rather are doing
today yep how about some other people
who are chasing chasing those leaders
what's going on with Denis Cade Rick
against Alexander fear looks like they
are in a rook endgame
yes which evaluation is unknown to me
well obviously white is the one who's
trying to win and I if I had to guess
I'd probably say equal chances whether
it's a win or a draw but I'd be quite
nervous if I was black here yeah like
he's done a good job activating his rook
that's good but you you can you can
easily see how white could divert black
away to try to block this to stop this B
pawn which would then allow the white
king to come in this way and target this
week eise exponent that's what I was
going to say the black King seems kind
of torn it needs to stop the b-pawn but
it absolutely cannot let
white capture on your own six because
they ve six enough five fault then
there's the two connected passers on the
kingside are going to win the game yep
so if I were inciting the guests I think
this looks very promising for white yep
totally agree
and the computer by the way thinks that
white is T pawns ahead so certainly the
computer thinks white has a very large
advantage I agree actually the more I
look at this I have to say maybe it's
better than even chances that white wins
this position this looks very difficult
for black indeed alright so that would
bring Denis up to three points out of
five which would still be a fair margin
behind these two leaders they've kind of
pull pulled away from the pack so to
speak but so definitely making progress
chipping away at that lead if the two
leaders don't manage to win today then I
think there's one more game we haven't
looked at if you're interested and that
is the game between Aman Hamilton and
Viktor me husky here we go yes yes
you're quite right and this is you know
it's interesting this game has been sort
of fairly equal for a while but in a
very interesting way yeah that finally
dynamically equal very dynamically equal
and with both sides the clock ticking
down you could imagine either as they
say sort of all three results are
possible here right so I will tell you
I'll just sort of play out what the
computer thinks is the best line the
computer does not like taking the work
as much as playing Bishop to e6 and then
after King h8 just 92
which I agree makes sense is the idea to
to actually capture this wreck enough
for the idea is feel like that's what
black wants is he yes Sigma yes maybe to
capture the look on f4 I think is sort
of the way to say it just sort of
threatening threatening threatening
maybe to capture that work it's a very
peculiar position because certainly
certainly you can see all kinds of ways
it could become very dynamically sort of
further imbalance but right now it kind
of looks like neither side can quite
break through but boy this is this is a
nail-biter I'd have to say and with so
little time left someone could make a
critical decision at some point that
could really change the evaluation of
this game my feeling is um say we make
some nothing move for black and then
white takes on f4 like what like a black
passes here you just Bishop a8 or
something well let's play Bishop d6 sure
if I play Knight takes f4 yeah you're
taking with the Jeep on I assumed you
know not at all clear okay both both
moves make sense and in this position
actually the computer prefers taking
with a pawn yeah because I would be five
squared I wanted to point out a problem
with taking with the Jeep on which seems
like the most natural to me if you do
take with the Jeep on I wanted to play
Bishop h4 and really I don't think g5 is
a move black wants to play because once
my bishop can get to this f5 square if a
rook lands on h3 you have some very very
serious problems with your king you know
I I'm afraid I have to disagree there
because after pushing the pawn to g5 and
then you just move the bishop and Knight
f6 actually I don't think that that
white really has any attack going at all
and meanwhile I think that black could
easily take things over by eventually
pushing this you know bringing this
bishop back to c8 and getting rid of the
this bishop on e6 and right I guess it's
all just a bit too slow for me if yeah
this knight on f6 covers of course at
the h7 square which is the one thing I
was looking at and I guess that would
not be the way to do it with yet yep
okay so we'll have to see what happens I
think we should definitely check back
into the
came in a few minutes because with the
clock ticking down with 10 moves to go
to the time control and with such a
complicated position something could
easily happen yeah
very difficult position so I think that
is all of the games for the moment so
where do you want to check back in on
well let's take a look back at the smear
and a Cobian game right you know it it
looks like a Cobian is just sort of
making steady steady kind of progress
here sort of repositioned his pieces but
I think someone's done a good job at
holding this it doesn't look to me like
either side has much of an advantage
so let's we'll click back a few moves
just so people can see in fact after
white played this move Knight to see one
black did in fact decide rather than
playing Knight cat6 to play Bishop e4 I
don't know whether that's the right move
but that was the decision he took smear
and understandably moved the knight to
d3
he chose this other path he chose this
other path for the knight which which
personally I don't like as much but
obviously a Cobian is thinking very hard
and probably seen much more than we are
so right he's only looking at his own as
we move away so white played this a2 a3
move with the idea perhaps of pushing
the pawn to b4 so black
lock that down white moves the rook to
e1 black moves the bishop back but
actually the the computer is not so
impressed at this point anymore and and
thinks basically in fact if anything
maybe white is slightly better or maybe
it's just an equal position MEA another
Cobian only has if I'm if I'm
understanding this correctly he only has
two minutes 45 seconds yeah maybe we had
a close-up of the actual board there
yeah the board came here to see what the
true standings are so yeah he's down to
two and a half minutes to a 13 minutes
and 20 seconds that's really quite
extraordinary because this is an
incredibly difficult position to play
when you're low on the clock because
it's just not at all clear what you
should be doing yeah I would actually
say here if I had to bet maybe the
position objectively is equal right but
I would be bad
the smear and has very good chances to
win just because a cobia needs to play
some moves and good moves fast yeah I
definitely agree
listen let's take a minute and just see
what happens here yeah I have to wonder
what was far as idea with putting this
knight on c6 the the only purpose I
really see it serving is it does control
this e5 square yeah so now the knight
the white knight at least cannot land on
that score quite so easily but from d6
it controls the e4 square it eyes this
weakness on c4 and I thought that night
would have been much better placed there
you know I don't know we'll have to ask
him afterwards if if he's in the mood to
talk
the clock is ticking I mean just by way
of context he's lost almost half his
time at this point without playing a
move and I could tell you from
experience at this point he's not
necessarily coming up with better ideas
by sitting in thinking it's it's a very
very difficult type of position to play
when it's just not at all clear what he
should be doing yeah obviously all
players handle time pressure differently
but yeah I feel like for a lot the way
it goes is you start thinking about how
low on time you are yes the last time
even thinking it looks to me like he's
melting down actually he is down - can
we take a look at that clock yeah he is
literally down below a minute
that's extraordinary I think we are I
think we are literally watching his game
tick away because he needs to come up
with an idea yeah you have to play
something here as the thing is if he
plays a move like he'll have to play
another move and another it's not a
position that plays itself it's a
position where you have to sort of like
decide what you want to do you see him
glance at the clock there yeah glance at
his invitation sheet oh my god oh my god
I have to make so many moves this is
really painful this just just play
something var play something okay 20
seconds
just just watching that timer tick down
it's very anxiety okay so the Queen d7
splint would it seems like a perfectly
reasonable move yeah a move that you
could play after five seconds yes is not
for a minute I totally agree with that
that he did not have to take so long he
ran and now we'll see if Ilya chooses to
respond rather quickly
put the other keeping the pressure on or
if he thinks this is where he needs to
spend his time just off hands there are
a few moves that I think white could
complain yeah but it should be said
since I mean we might as well turn our
attention back to the actual right board
a little bit the computer does not like
Queen d7 and thinks that white actually
has a solid advantage after just a very
simple straightforward move which is not
f2 and the idea here is we're gonna lead
to the exchange of bishops we're gonna
trade works now all very simple
straightforward moves but now look
what's happened now suddenly we have
this very bad bishop on a7 and whites
pieces are quite well placed and blacks
knight on c6 it looks active but
actually you can see it's it's not
really doing anything because all these
squares are either blocked or controlled
by the opponent so yeah not lost not
lost by any stop by any stretch
now I'm not pleasant but if it was
actually been been played knows okay and
we see a yeah the players go down for
this line pretty quickly yep so while
that is a good position for white it's
an interesting practical decision that
white is made because the blacks
position does not look great there but
it is a little bit simpler than this
position that he had previously can we
zoom in on that clock and see where are
we now on the time yeah so with the 32nd
increment he's back above a minute and
at this point the thirty second matters
enormous lead is very very so yeah
that's literally double the amount of
time he has maybe Ilya had even better
chances if he found some way to keep it
a bit more complex than this because now
bar gets to play three or four easy
moves get that time bank building up
just a little bit and then
before you know it's back to the serious
pressure yeah I will say though on the
other hand yeah this is a very pleasant
position for what I mean it's it's tough
to disagree with good chess moves yeah I
mean this this is a win or draw right I
mean that's that's basically what we're
looking at ran I can easily imagine
either result it's very hard to imagine
white losing this position of course it
could happen you can make a mistake and
so forth but with normal moves here this
is either win or draw and not to drive
this point into the ground but you can
really imagine if this night were on d6
in this position it's a whole different
story
yes yes yes yes I agree if black had
maneuvered the knight from E to C a d6
and E for a very different dynamics here
the night is really badly placed on a c6
square thank you well maybe good chances
for Illya then which is not something I
expected just you know just a few short
minutes ago so perhaps today is a day
for the players in the bottom of the
leaderboard and the a group al exhibit
off of course with that b6 position
where he is still I think just up a
clean piece years very quickly but Iliad
looking really to press in this position
as well yes and they're in the endgame
we were just looking at and now we've
we've gone back to the epitaphs game
just momentarily and I mean to be
perfectly honest I don't know why
they're still playing yeah this is this
is quite over but Wow yeah all right so
it'll be interesting to a it'll be
interesting to yeah see see how this
game shakes out let's go to the back to
this temple game it's really gotten very
very exciting so
so let's let's go back a few moves so we
can sort of catch up to what happened
here she look pretty pretty interesting
so so black maneuvering these nights
around a little bit yeah so remember we
we left off in this position I'm not
sure what this night move does it sort
of looks active but actually if anything
I I preferred the night on e6 rather
than f4 right especially with it's not
an age five yeah that night if it's
going anywhere they probably wanted to
go to this F force yeah you know but so
if we just click ahead a couple more
moves here we'll see
so we rerouted to a very nice looted and
now black decided to make a very
fundamental change in the position and
push the pawn to c5 interesting very
understandable of course on doubling the
pawns and yet and and trading pawns to
yet which might help and yet making the
making whites rooks more active because
before with this more compact pawn
structure here really you know with
these pawns here very difficult for
whites rooks to really sort of break
through anywhere um and yeah I did what
I mentioned just quickly Alexander
epitaphs has in fact won his game
against the seat der by Lee believe what
had resigned in that position yeah as
expected
I'd be expected so now after the
exchange of pawns it sort of looks like
black is getting more active but I would
say if anything it looks to me like
white is becoming more active you see
the interesting thing here is the pawn
itself is kind of less important than
whether White's rooks get let out of
their box or and start roaming the board
and it looks like what's about to happen
is this Bishop can move to c3 and this
rook can move to b1 and then all of a
sudden this rook becomes active and
meanwhile these Knights here as you
pointed out that's not on h5 in
particular quite
massive you know boris spassky once said
many years ago that this particular
night formation when you have sort of
one night stuck defending another as a
particularly dangerous one it can look
active yeah actually turn out to be sort
of passive and brittle these these
nights defend each other but they also
kind of get locked into place yeah kind
of exactly they're sort of locked into
place and and that's kind of what's
happened here so I should say the
computer thinks that white is up upon in
this position in terms of the the
magnitude of his advantage and that was
better than he was doing before I did
want to mention I do understand where
blacks coming from with this though
honestly uh one of the best way to try
to draw these games I think is to just
start counting the pawns all right all
right three pawns to go if I take off
this deep on two pawns to go yeah if he
runs out of pawns I'm not gonna lose
this game yep which well that's a very
straightforward way to try to draw like
you said he's giving white some activity
and so it's he's giving Wiseman white
some activity and I'm I did want to
mention some yep some huge things are
happening in the Aman Hamilton game
against Victor Michalowski Victor
actually chose to capture on f4 but not
with a minor piece he took with a rook
so not even accepting the exchange
instead choosing to capture on f4 as a
fair trade oh wow let's let's bounce
back to this game yeah so as we were
saying you know things could happen
and holy cow have they ever by the way
if the computer could puke it would be
doing it right now it does not like what
what white just did and I must admit
it's very strange
I'm very puzzled I feel to take enough
for surely you should do it with the
night yeah but also why take on f4 it's
a very interesting puzzling choice so
here we are so apparently he thinks he
has an attack the computer if the
computer could laugh I think the
computer would stop puking and start
laughing because the computer actually
it
it's telling that the computer thinks
that black has a completely winning
position if he plays - totally either of
two totally different moves so on the
one hand the computer thinks that white
is five pawns up if he moves the pawn to
h5 there's just no attack well there's
so I'm sorry used to black yeah black is
winning
Black has won on the other hand the
computer thinks excuse me the black is
three and a half palms up if he pushes
this pawn to b4 just completely stopping
the Queen from coming to the sea yes
that was I think White's main story all
right kind of play he wanted to play
Queen c3 check for his King on to some
bad score and then check right so it
looked a bit unrealistic so we'll have
to ask him if he's what is the line
after h5 in that position actually sure
live Queen c3 check had to be the idea
well interestingly the computer doesn't
even think it's worth playing the Queen
c3 checked it's simply nothing no reason
to do it so play h5 the computer just
wants to move the knight back then you
just know let's let's force it so quince
III check and the command obviously
black has to move the King well not
obviously I guess but I guess obviously
you don't move the King to f8 that would
be a disaster
because that would be checkmate so I
guess the main point of h5 is it gives
your Kings h7 squares as well as the
time well it also attacks tonight
exactly so so now after this King h7 I
mean there's no way to save both pieces
for weight right no so I mean we can
just sort of I mean we can sort of
pretend that there's an attack and take
the knight on d7 so yes it's true you
don't want to take back because if
Knight f6 check but so what by the way
block can just play Queen takes pawn
check which is going to force an
exchange and just win everything but
also by the way black can also take this
knight on g4 which also works just fine
okay
so yeah I don't know
yeah had to be some some mistake in
calculation but now interestingly Amon
has played a different move altogether
Wow Peter's not happy with this move
still thinks Black has an advantage in
fairness the both players are quite low
on time yet I feel like h5 was was a
very findable move well I was very fond
of all and to be honest I think pushing
the pawn to b4 to me it was an extremely
human move to play just really sort of
take control of the of the dark squares
clamped down the attack it's very
interesting I don't know what's going on
here but does not feel does not feel
like the best movement so so critically
here the computer thinks that white
should play Queen to c3 yeah I mean what
else this was White's main point yeah
which is why Knight f6 strikes me so
strange is you're forcing your opponent
to play the move that he wanted to play
yeah yeah yeah now I agree with the pawn
to h5 was a very natural move it attacks
tonight it gives the King to h7 Square
of course after it moved like b4 from
black here there's simply Queen e5 from
white and white does have enough squares
now to stay on this time let's have
enough squares it's still basically a
winning position for white foot block
excuse me but let's just play this line
out so as you point out why can put the
Queen on e5 black and chase the Queen
now if if you play the Queen to d4 h5
actually is a good position for black
but you know yeah plays a saddle just as
it takes you can buy eggs the computer
actually wants to move the Queen out
here to a 7 but black moves the Queen
back to e7 Bishop f2 Bishop c8 you just
you get the feeling he's he's getting
the same positions he would have gotten
except he's not up a piece yeah I think
that's a good way of Greater I mean I
mean we can keep playing but the basic
point is block is up upon it's a good
pong blocks pieces are well placed it
certainly looks like block
when but it's not over over whereas
before it could have just been over over
and we'll go back why did play the Queen
to c3 it's on the board yeah oh and it
looks like we actually have a result
here in the Dennis cadra game against
Alexander fear those players let's see
if we can pull up that position
oh well yet Black has resigned yeah what
was on as expected then I wanted to make
sure nothing too crazy happened so um
why don't we bounce to that game just
quickly of course this was the very very
difficult rook endgame I'm talking
that's exactly right so so let's just
see
find a good good spot here quite a lot
of moves happen so we have to sort of
yes so we last left off around here rook
a3 I think was was like strong yeah so
sorry about that I'm still learning how
to use the interface here so I have to I
have to overcome the latency effect here
so what happened was so here we were and
black faced this fundamental choice
which is do you stop the white king from
penetrating over here and then let white
get over to the e2 week e6 pawn or do
you hold the week six pawn and let white
penetrate we can see exactly what choice
was made but what ended up happening was
white was able to just push through I
won't go through these these end games
can be quite complicated so I won't try
to go through and analyze them in detail
suffice to say that black did not find
the right the most accurate defense and
then this last move here actually a bit
of a blunder just allowing yg4 with
basically wins right away forcing this
exchange here of the pawns
yeah and so well we had wrap-up designs
games after King d7 why placed upon the
b7 and there's nothing to do to stop the
pump yeah I did want to mention we
actually I believe have a player ready
to come in for an interview often so
well I switch out here why don't we take
a look at one more game and see
I don't know it looks like some progress
is being made let's take a look at the
alias' Mira and vara Cobian so well
actually go ever you well let's let's go
back to the Hambleton game right well
we'll go back to the group a but this
has gotten wildly exciting black has
actually played an inferior move so if
you remember we were back here and we
thought that black had excuse me for
that auto-update we'll come back here
black actually had two very strong moves
he could play the pawn to b4 or it could
move the Bishop to b4 he chose instead
to move the bishop to d4 it's not as
crazy it may look at first because in
fact there is this pin against the the
Queen which is where we are now but now
all of a sudden this position much less
clear because it's really two White's
favored to have traded the dark square
bishop for the light square bishop and
to have gotten this opposite color
bishop and pull not endgame but this
obstacle bishop position after for
example Knight takes f6 Queen takes f6
Bishop f2 so still black is to be
preferred very complicated position much
less clear than it had been much less of
an advantage than it been just a couple
moves ago when in fact black had a
completely winning position now much
less clear and of course we have to
point out both sides
less than a minute 1/2 on their clock so
who knows what's going to happen as this
game unfolds so thank you very much for
joining us would you like to drive a bit
and show us your game yeah okay can I
get the mouse oh sorry well sorry fun
true
once you click here on the Oh computer
oh yeah go ahead please yep alright
where's my game first of all
this
yeah so we were watching this and and
you know for a while it looked like yeah
sorry about that well it's it's hard to
flip the board sorry you're gonna have
to look at how far back do you want to
go do you want to go back to the
beginning is there a particular point
that you'd like to zero in on no when we
saw at the beginning actually why don't
you explain to us the the choice you
made with your opening so 1 B 6 is not
normal well I'm thinking closest I mean
so I don't have time to prepare
I'm just lazy and in the second since
I'm - - so before the tournament I was
happy was nine drawers but it seems like
people wanted to beat me because I'm
rusty haven't played for nine months so
at some point I got angry and had to
start playing something for a winner so
you just society imbalance things
I mean before streaming right sure -
there's too much I think sure okay so so
we got to this position and and white
made the instant decision to push on e5
push e5 right away what do you think
about that I mean seems like a principle
continuation but I thought they'd have D
5 D 5 95 right and my bishop is playing
so it's like a very double-edged
position I mean yeah somebody like my
approach wasn't to play some objectively
good position for myself just to get
some imbalance position hope to like to
complicate matters how do you analyze
this okay okay so you're just playing as
it comes
excellent so Bishop b5 and Knight ft7
and B 496 and certainly it does seem
like you've managed to get your pieces -
yeah Bishop um just risk weighting
betterment yeah yeah absolutely it seems
like the early development Bishop to g5
may not have business to promote h6
right yeah and to rent my movie 697
right so yeah in here I mean until my
sister and maybe could have done
something else I don't know so you were
happy to gain some space on the
queenside
I mean it's also a concession because
I'll give him d4 square that's why I
played 96 back not to not allow him 94
right yes what how did you evaluate this
position at this point in your mind I
didn't I just I don't evaluate I mean
I'd like were you happy with your
position yeah I mean it was quite
unclear him it was about what was going
well
yeah so I mean I leaned towards a
practical approach I mean I didn't know
what was going on and I'm sure that my
point also like it wasn't
were there any decisions he made that
you did not agree with for example this
pawn to h5 did you also seems like a
principle continuation I didn't know so
you felt like maybe he was trying to
punish you sort of like try to try to
get an advantage as much again I didn't
ever leave position that too much I was
just playing because I know thinking too
much right okay
oh here I thought I mean I have to
eliminate his LightSquared Bishop so
here I did I have to do this otherwise
he might create some threats on b1 h7
Dagon oh right okay so the so just to
explain to the viewers so your thought
your thinking was after what had played
this aged 5g5 this principled decision
to sort of open up this diagonal here
you thought okay it's time to exchange
the light square bishop off to make sure
that it won't ever be a danger even at
the cost of this palm but yes into them
you've got good that much I visually it
looked good and usually I just trust my
intuition there you go but when I enter
to complicated position sometimes my
intuition lets me down where I get in
time trouble then I'm in okay sure so I
again just have to ask that what did you
think of your position at this point
where you have I said I was yeah I had
good compensation I think and my
opponent wasn't sure about this mo kio
suggesting something else something else
I don't remember you know and instead of
quantity six years just 27 I think oh
okay so which is I saw this moment well
but some reason couldn't be six gonna be
five like good yeah 27 zero what's here
suggests it looks good as well right
Frank when he's six and he just said
something after that yeah the Queen do
seven let's say Becky's doing better I'm
in there yeah
26 let's say a bishop f3 he said Bishop
a 3gf 394 I saw a bishop a three of
course right yeah so what about whatever
he said seems like at first lion so
maybe I've assimilated the position here
I didn't want to trade here's a there's
four bishop yeah I understand the whites
King is exposed but I thought amendment
certainly a very very imbalanced
position White has two connected passed
pawns but on the other hand the King
side spin Shambo tonight is out of night
is out of play
well if if the Queen's were off suddenly
the Knights would be in play but yes
Knights out of play and the Kings are in
danger a very very very imbalanced
position but instead yes we might plan
to although I did the position better
that's fine yeah Queen b6 rook takes
Queen B 5
certainly the as you can see the engine
thinks it's
basically an equal position yeah so
seems like probably probably you agreed
and then here Y played a blundered yeah
just a blunder right do you think
neither before he hit the play yeah he
didn't see 9g for it wait did you for
yeah Wow blunder yeah sure okay so
basically at this point our Queen takes
Queen rook takes Queen and just didn't
didn't see this move G for pushing the
night away creating the threat of Knight
takes Knight with this pin of the pawn
like against everybody well yeah yeah
sorry let me check 94 instead sure I
said I have compensation but they did
again I was lazy to calculate two things
I was just playing based on intuition 94
so going to my opponent I mean I have to
be precise here so what do you think we
think he 19th Nidoqueen Jeff I saw a
field the first line to give up Quinn
for Turk's i'm sorry ii like the first
line 94 94 couldn't before but I don't
think I would go I would have gone for
it but I saw this like 1994 CB 34 Queen
takes before it looks pretty
extraordinary but the point is after
pawn takes you're gonna get this Shaco
Bishop a2 and then you take this rook
and now come up tonight I have Brooke DD
one and okay Sean ideas but again I
didn't like something maybe Quinn bit
too mm-hm
serve my coordination yeah Queen B -
Brooke d1 and most likely wise will find
some Perpetual mentor
yep it's interesting how for the
computer is sort of like always equal no
matter what right yeah we play different
moves doesn't doesn't really care which
way you take right goodnight yeah I
suppose fine but I'm not sure I would I
would have played actually I had nothing
I mean like planned against an identity
for I thought maybe he wouldn't play
this move a minute and you're quite
right so so you were saying maybe find a
perpetual I think that's exactly what's
happened is six
f5 Queen a4 yeah and now all of a sudden
this is gonna end up being the perpetual
check yeah back and forth so just to
show the viewers
black can play f4 this Bishop on g3 is
trapped a white is just going to play
check black moves the King up
and it is perpetual check so certainly
not saying and by the way if black moves
the bishop to f8 it was a terrible
mistake because I don't feel like this
when to quit him seven second is exactly
so um of course none of this is forced
but just to illustrate your point that
you just always seem to have enough
activity yeah that's what I thought but
I didn't see anything concrete yeah so
the the key error that yeah
was this night BTW for move we're just
just to go back to show the viewers one
last time this night BTW for a mistake
and instead night ft for the correct
move probably holding some sort of
equality yeah yeah i didn't say anything
that's what i have enough great yeah
great well okay well thank you very much
for joining us and congratulations how
to find win thank you yeah thank you
very much
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error instead boogie through the
city and discover the music that gave
the Blues their name at the National
Blues Museum Broadway Oyster Bar or even
the legendary Blueberry Hill so whether
you love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring earlier like much much easier
with ok well tell you what um so so
we're joined by Dennis conscious thank
you very much for being here and our
congratulations on you on your win so
very interesting end game and also quite
a very interesting mill game that we
didn't really I'm here have much chance
much opportunity to go through why don't
you talk to us about what you think some
of the interesting points in the game
were well I mean interesting it was I
guess the opening like it it looked very
very good for me from the opening from
the from the start it looked like white
is much better later on I don't know
like the endgame was kind of I mean it's
not so interesting for I guess for the
people who are watching but yeah like
Bishop before I'm not sure like it
looked just very nice for me yeah yeah
like that didn't bitter like that
doesn't think anything of it but but it
looked I mean you just have such a big
grip in the position yeah you're okay
Chi 1 and now okay I was thinking rook
c8 Queen a7 what is he playing so on
work c8 Queen a7 he just sacrificed his
rook c3 just wants to sacrifice although
actually the computer is not in fact the
computer thinks maybe even work c7 which
is quite funny ok but all it means is
Queen b6 and and and rook takes c3 but
let's let's take a look takes Knight
just for just for fun
and now the computer actually does not
want to take the rook wants to take the
bishop instead okay the computer plays
BC Bishop a3 and then Queen CA yeah okay
I wasn't even considering of course
something like that
something like this but okay first of
all I told that I have Queen b7 after
oxytree but then I didn't see the Queen
c8 move that's the thing yet after rook
c3 Queen b7 black has the very good move
Queen c8 I didn't see that one yeah
and then I have to exchange Queens well
white is probably still slightly better
but about nothing really
yeah not a lot well so we have a lot to
get through so I think what we can what
we can say here is your opponent played
Bishop e7 years and probably rook c8
very dynamic and difficult to evaluate
but looks like it was a I guess yeah it
is really good if it's like if the
tactics work
yeah the move you want apply that's it
so but at any rate he played Bishop e7
and then you you took advantage of the
opportunity to trade the bishop I don't
understand the wedding bureau doesn't
think so much what happens if he castles
instead of taking because my idea was to
play 95 can i what is it my move Yahoo 5
yes 95 yes I'm here black cannot move at
all I think yeah I mean the only thing
that I was calculating here was night e8
now yeah
98 I take Bishop e7 Queen e7 Queen d7
Queen g5 check King be one Queen e5
Queen b7 and now on 96 because the rook
is hanging on a 8 yeah 96 I have Queen
c7 yep and rook d8 I think I just win a
piece with f4 e 5 yes it's exactly yeah
Queen if he plays now rook the ADA I
think it's just gonna be a 4 or a 5
the computer won't even look at yes ok
but but will will point it out to the
viewers that rook b8 will either work
but at any rate f4 Queen takes e5 + e5
and you kind of protect and you cannot
protect you can play see if I can just
play this
correct and and the final tactic is on
this rook takes night and now of course
this allows for takes rules so he didn't
go for this we didn't go for it but
again we've got a lot to get through so
we'll get the Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes Bishop of course block has taken
an extra move next to tempo to trade
these bishops so it's very advantageous
for you and this is just looks like a
plus an advantage right now before is a
really good move
I'm not letting him play rook c6 and
actually my idea is night at 5:00 yeah
so I think don't move g6 right yeah
because after 94 my huge trip is Knight
a5 that black cannot really do anything
except playing g6 yeah so so black
played g6 to stop that and now I go if I
because there's no Roxy 8 and the knight
has to go back or actually he jumped on
g4 which is which should be just losing
somehow very fast but I didn't see it
yeah well I mean I mean we sort of
letting stockfish sort of turn away for
a few seconds but I guess yeah ok yeah
Brooke get to actually makes more sense
because then there are no Queen g5
chicks and and there are no there is no
night at 5 because night at 5 is always
annoying for me right yeah so Brooke d2
makes lots of sense
really to was the better move for sure
94 but obviously this is very pleasant
this I mean this should be yeah yeah
rookie for what did he play Michael
Knight a 5 out of 5
Knight takes pawn takes so basically
you've just you're just waiting upon
right yes that's what ended up happening
a 5 I'm here I was actually considering
to play something like not to take the
pawn but to maybe play g4 yeah I was I
had some ideas to play g4 FG or g4 yeah
but it's it's interesting actually the
the computer doesn't want to take this
pawn it wants to play some move it's
trying to decide it's at f4 is it b3 is
it a three some move to try to
strengthen insertion before taking I was
also thinking the same basically but
then I just took cos okay let's there's
a tape on let's first take it so take
castles
404 I went to the rock back play rock c5
okay I think this moves are just they're
not really a lot to say because okay but
here he made a huge mistake
Rudi 800k he took took h5 was okay now
probably might move okay I played not
rugby six my idea is actually h4 is a
good move mmm-hmm you think if you think
in each for was a mistake yes because
I'm getting the pawn for free a rook the
three root page three that was my idea
that's why I just played rugby sixth not
letting him to play f6 basically not
exchanging pawns and now I'm gonna like
if he plays now King g6 let's say then
he threatens h4 then I would play
probably h4 on my own because then the
King is even more far away from getting
king of faith King e7 and then like I
would try slowly with c4 King C to rugby
three rooks III taking the pawns okay
that was my idea but actually an h4
should be good yes be okay I mean the
bigger things this is good rook c8 I
mean has to go back with the rock rock
h3 and now rocket-shaped yeah and
suddenly here's the protected sauce yeah
I mean the tactic that he actually has
that I cannot play g3 because my idea
was to play g3 touji tree just winning
but g3 he takes hg and if I take R okay
change yeah that would have been a bad
one to fall so I was thinking actually
instead of c4 what if I play King b2 so
Rho KJ - can i play now King B - yes and
then he has to play rook b8 yeah because
now I have tactic like King b2 let's say
and let's say black tries to keep the
same thing he plays rook h6 very same
but no it doesn't work because rook h6g
3hg rock h6 and then G to rock h3 yeah
and at the end I'll just give a check
right so now it's not check anymore
yes Queen so I should have tracking B to
but I was thinking okay c4 should be
just winning but it wasn't it was
actually very difficult position king
see - yes the thing is whenever I play
g3 he will just go rook d8 yeah and then
d to create g3
yaki Nissan was a bad I think you should
have just went immediately to exchange
the pawns go for some e5 stuff yeah just
exchange as many points as possible
that's what I was thinking that should
be close to maybe a draw
still of course black has very hard time
I mean to us to defend but needs to need
to activate and if white places he just
goes back I guess ya know he gets from
g3 and then he gets very active and then
pawn on e5 will probably just fall it
because as is so often the case in these
end games the most important things to
activate the work yes because he can
also just always play a four that's the
thing if I attack the pawn with rook c5
a four be a and then it's a very simple
job yeah
so that's interesting so King e7 may
have been a critical mistake the ephod
may have been a good a good try yeah you
should have good like where you and in
fact if we can just the computer
actually wants to do this and okay yes
yes yes of course I saw this know you're
thinking that actually like this is this
is winning for right that's what I was
thinking during the game I'm gonna take
on a5 and then I'm gonna play to on the
flank against this one pawn but it's not
so clear I'm clear the point is very
active you may have to give something in
yes so probably this should be just a
droid then but obviously a very
difficult decision to make here if
you're trying to draw so but exactly the
kind of thing it might be objectively
correct but but practically very hard to
take the decision in that moment and
instead he played a more passive move
which allowed you to consolidate
somewhat still very unclear I wasn't
sure like here now he played H AJ I
think he's always a mistake because this
makes my life much easier right when
when there is a pollen h4 I always think
can you go to the second rankles right
right now I have no weaknesses because
after AG AG no I don't have to protect
the third-ranked
yeah in fact this h2 pawn can sometimes
be at least as weak is that yes I always
have to think about now the second rank
also and the third ring because he can
always play hg yep so I think this move
was was a mistake for him because now it
makes it much easier for me to the
yeah but then then he played not rugby
five I think yes and now I took a lot of
time because now I see his idea is
actually to push a 5 again but this bit
but like this before moved looked very
nice to me
oh sorry you didn't you play Kingston I
was thinking about to play before but I
wasn't sure what after E 5 before E 5 fe
Fe a be a for rookie 5 ok
the computer says that position is
winning but I was like in my head if he
exchanges all the pawns I have the a
pawn is not so simple
no of course this is very difficult yeah
so I mean still his King is totally cut
so should be winning but I wasn't I just
wasn't that short that's all that's why
I didn't play it no did using these end
games how sometimes like it requires
some transformation like this and it's a
win and it's always hard to decide what
ok so here basically I spent like 20
minutes or half an hour because I was
calculating a 5 now I wasn't even
thinking about the mood that he played
you gave me check after which I think
should be just very simple win for me
right this is King before and before but
what up there Aoife ok so you think
there was a good comment one of the
thinking if I was thinking King c4 to
play actual not dead ok what what are
the hero likes both both King c4 and F
takes always ways every 5 so much
winning every 5 rookie fire what then
it doesn't say rookie fun rookie 5
okay he goes for this position just just
just to push his pawns well just because
the king is I mean if you can yes oh
okay okay so Pro this was a very
actually simple ones yeah because in
fact if anything the addition of these
pawns probably helps you baby yes yes
yes being is simply because it cuts this
rook off and they're kind of like black
can't even try it to change it up d6 or
something exactly exactly right yeah
that's right okay okay so this is a very
actual simple wing I didn't realize that
I wanted to play something else I was
considering like if I King c-4 no evil
that's the thing okay so well well we'll
have to go to the critical yes the last
critical because we're running short on
time
listen let's sort of spool ahead I know
the thing about these rook and pawn in
games they look so so dry but actually
they're so okay no no here no I think
you just lost because yeah my position
is very very simple
is there a moment you thought that he he
made an error here
yeah like only at the end I want to
check some okay because he really just
losing but maybe at the end I made a
mistake
first here I repeated yeah because now
kini sick the correct move d5
okay three okay okay okay okay no no
this is not lost if he gives check what
happens if he plays something like if he
plays rook d5 no no no Rudy five I just
pushed you for probably twenty four I
what an rooks e5 that was a thing
because he will have rook she is he
gonna have rook c8 okay so now b6 yeah
okay okay no like my idea was somehow to
get this position I know like it's
always lost okay yeah okay so you're
just losing because I have this g4 trick
yeah but I I guess I made a mistake
because I didn't take immediately on e5
I first push b5 or something what did I
do
because well but in this position you
play g4 I don't know here just winning
okay can you go back for a second sure
just go go more back when he pushed a
five and now here what did I play
b5 I played yeah that's a terrible move
actually because before then he can take
on f4 but my idea was after ef4 I
thought I'm winning after king he said I
think him but then maybe he will just
sacrifice his rook for the pawn and and
get with the King to the pawns yes
he's gonna play now rook b1 and on b6
just king d6 yeah no way to well I mean
we can just make this first yeah of
course first pawn sake F G and now yeah
okay so here I made actually I yeah a
huge mistake at the end yeah because you
can you can basically get it down to
rook versus pawn and huh because I think
actually like the position if I have f4
f5 and if I push King a 6 b 6 can be it
there could be a draw for black very
easily you'll just keep his rook on that
fate and just play king me king b8 i
think that is a draw so so i guess the
game was full of mistakes from both
sides i I think well if you ever if you
ever read any of these classic rook and
pawn and game books which I'm sure you
have all these great these games between
these great world champions there's
always mistakes back and forth on both
sides yeah the rest of us mere mortals
the same thing so they I was the lucky
one I guess well you you had the better
position although it is easy to be lucky
with
well congratulations welder let's all
right thank you
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50/50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
yeah welcome back to our live coverage
here once again another very exciting
offer from Ryan Chester there be sure to
check out those golden ticket raffles as
always I'm back as Caleb Denby it's been
a while since you last saw me so I'll
reintroduce myself thank you too Dennis
Kendrick and al accept tough yeah great
interviews great games
I'm Patrick wolf yeah and it's a
pleasure to be analyzing these games
with you and there's a couple of
interesting games that we can check in
on before we wrap up today yeah
running short on time here so we'll look
at a couple of the most really relevant
games to to our tournament standings and
call it a day yeah let's start with the
the smearin games so you'll remember
that a Cobian had a lot of pressure
getting to time control well he did
manage to get to time control however
woops sorry I'm gonna have to click back
here he did manage to get time control
however his position has basically
unraveled in doing so so when last we
checked in we saw that smeared had a
very very pleasant position it was clear
that either it was going to be a win for
white or it was going to be a draw but
you know really smearing was the one
playing for wearing a cobia loose just
trying to hang on roundabouts here is
where we is where we left off white just
started playing very very sensible
logical moves here g4 opening up this
kingside here creating the second
weakness Black has this weak pawn this
weak pawn this Bishop is passive this
Knight is passive so now what white is
doing is opening up a second front
forcing black to make some difficult
decisions threats on all sides of the
boys rats on all sides 97 actually a
mistake allowing white to bring the
Queen in attack the bishop in the knight
brought the bishop back the exchange of
pawns so now there's half 5 pawn is an
additional weakness this c5 pawn
impossible to defend
in fact like simply didn't even try
Queen takes pawn Queen d7 93 this
outstandingly placed knight on D
blocking the deep on defending the
f-pawn a couple more moves and what we
see here is white just has a solid extra
pawn and this d4 pawn probably about to
drop computer thinks that white is
literally three pawns up in this endgame
and in other words the advantage is
overwhelming and smear and should one
should be more than enough that's C pawn
just going to walk up the board slowly
but surely
yeah and too many weaknesses for black
and so why don't we take a look at yeah
this this game before we wrap up here
Jack's Jim buyuk of course one of the
leaders in the B group
how does himself quite the technical
tasks against even Zurich why the
technical tasks indeed as a matter of
fact it does it looks like it's he no
longer really has an advantage at all
but let's go back a few moves when last
we checked into this game we were at
this point we said okay whites rooks are
starting to get more active even at the
cost of the pawn and for a while
everything was sort of going according
to plan
computer likes this position but whoops
this pawn this this move not so good
computer actually much prefers that
white move the King to c2 just get out
of the way first preserve it's not
necessary to take that pawn right away
yeah like we said you know these these
last two pawns are very precious for
white he needs one of them in order to
win this game but instead after taking
his pawn on f5 takes the bishop with
Chuck and yes it is true white is
getting the piece back however getting
the piece back in a way that doesn't
really allow him to do much with his
remaining works yes the King looks
exposed but in fact there's no way to
organize any sort of mating attack not
enough material not enough material left
and well tabbouleh ACCA's is thinking
here but it's not at all clear that he
has anything better than a draw the
computer at this point thinks it's just
an equal position quite a turn of events
very very effective and really valiant
defense by Stephens ear to to hold what
probably to hold what was a clearly lost
position
all right well a few viewers at home are
still interested in these games as they
still seem to have some some chests left
to be played you're welcome to follow
along on us chess champs calm
unfortunately this is about where we
have to wrap up our show so why don't we
take a quick look at the results in
round five here and see where we stand
so Ilya smearin is hoping to convert
that game against VAR a Cobian in the a
group the sieve der Bali of course lost
this game to alexander epitaphs dropping
further from where he once stood as the
sole leader Jordan won forest when a
very nice game against Alexander bortnik
with some fun Queen sacrifices to wrap
it up Darras wits drew his game against
Toronto cumin and Alex Linderman is
still playing against Ray Robson here it
seems as though they still have a fairly
equal position and over in the B group
we have Viktor Michalowski
playing his game against Amon Hamilton
of course that game with that
back-and-forth you know takes on f4 was
was that game that we looked at they're
still unclear what that results going to
be
romka Cobian drew his game against
meanwhile Petrosyan yes sir Quesada
Perez one of the group B leaders is
still up against a veteran gorian that
game looking to be quite equal still
still some chess left to be played there
Denis quadric won his game against
Alexander fear and Denis is really the
third guy to look out for in this B
group if Jackie Nasser don't manage to
win today which it's looking as though
they might not dennis is going to be the
next closest guy to to chase them and of
course
Jack's team bully AK is still playing
against Steven Zurich and what was our
key matchup of the day and like we said
we just looked at this game it's looking
tough to win for white very tough yeah
so it's really anybody's game in the a
group tons and tons of players like I
said up near the top there in in the B
group it is the story of first these two
players Jackson buyuk yes sir Quesada
Perez and now it's looking as though
Denis Kendrick is the the clear third
place player to watch for yep so Patrick
it's been wonderful having you here I
did want to mention you're not here just
for commentary right you're teaching a
class tonight at 7 p.m.
well yes I've given a lecture so I so
over 20 years ago I published a book
called the completely
to chess which is basically a basic
chess book it was the last thing I did
before retiring from chess as a
professional and moving on to other
things the publisher came back to me
last year actually and said we're
reviving the series well the books been
in print ever since it's done pretty
well actually but but they're they're
rebranding it so now instead of play the
Complete Idiot's Guide to chess it's a
play chess like a boss not my choice of
title but I put some time into bringing
things up to date and in particular I
really completely revamp the chapter on
computers in chess and so tonight I'm
gonna be giving a lecture on computers
and chess with a particular focus on
artificial intelligence how AI works and
what else
how alpha 0 employed artificial
intelligence how it works how it's
different from the other top chess
engines and and a little bit of history
of that very interesting stuff so if you
are in the st. Louis area be sure to
join us tonight at 7 p.m. for that very
special lecture if you are a YouTube
viewer this will not be live-streamed
however it will be recorded so keep and
keep a look out on the YouTube channel
we will be uploading that videos shortly
other than that what do you expect from
this tournament is the last time we get
to talk to you but any clear favourites
you think well I don't know I mean there
have been a number of really exciting
games and I have to say in the B group
in particular I've been very very
impressed by John Bullock and by Dennis
caters so I realized that's that's
that's the B group and you're supposed
to pay attention to the a group but you
sort of go where the chess takes you
right yeah meanwhile of course Ray
Robson is a very very exciting chess
player it just so happens that the two
games we were looking at today not as
exciting but I'm sure that we'll have
some really exciting chess coming from
him and some of the others as well so
definitely nothing determined yet going
to have to keep an eye so be sure to
join us tomorrow I will be back with
Dennis Boros talking about these games
with you we're going to be here through
the end of the tournament 3:30 p.m. as
always for our start time be sure to
join us next time for more coverage of
the fall chess class
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you